nearly a hundred firefighters rushed in
to help oh there goes
after a massive five-alarm fire ripped
through an apartment building under
construction in Charlotte Thursday
morning the city's fire chief said the
intense Blaze trapped firefighters on
two separate occasions but others were
able to rescue them in all firefighters
rescued 15 workers from the construction
site including one who was trapped on a
crane for more than an hour hoisted
hundreds of feet above the Raging Fire
Crews also had to work quickly to put
out Flames that spread to nearby
buildings we had a number of rooftop
bars due to the the Embers that were
just traveling all over the place due to
the volume and size of the fire you have
a number of investigators here that will
determine the cause